RYAN LOREN: Hello, Margo.
MARGOT B: Hi, Ryan.
RYAN LOREN: Thanks for
being here tonight.
I'm really excited to have you.
MARGOT B: Thanks for having me.
This is fun to be at Google.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah, totally.
So I just wanted to
talk to you a little bit
about your background and a
little bit about your music.
And then we'll get started.
So can you tell people
about you that might not
know who you are about your
music, your background?
MARGOT B: Sure.
I grew up in Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
I come from a very
eclectic family.
My mother, who is
Russian-German, and my father,
originally from Jamaica and
moved to the United States
when he was 16.
So he has an interesting story.
And then they met in college
and produced me, which is great.
I'm thankful.
And I've lived in New
York for five years,
working independently
as a singer-songwriter
and working as a songwriter
for other artists
and touring with other artists.
I just finished
"Rent" off Broadway.
It just closed in September.
And doing other shows in
the meantime but getting
back to my music.
So it's exciting.
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
If you could quickly summarize
your experience with "Rent,"
how would you say that,
or what would you say?
MARGOT B: Life changing.
It was something that
I will always remember.
And I never expected it to
be so hard to say goodbye.
But that family is
such a huge family.
"Rent" was such an
unbelievable show that totally
changed the face of musical
theater for rock and everything
and changing the
way that it's sung
and the way that it
just looks to everyone.
And as a kid, I grew
up with that show.
So it's kind of weird to
be doing book reports when
you were younger and
then be in the show
and sitting with the director
and the writer's father
and being invited over
to family dinners.
And it was life changing.
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
I was lucky enough
to get to see you.
MARGOT B: Yeah.
We had a lot of fun
jumping around and swinging
from the rafters.
RYAN LOREN: You did very well.
It was pretty good.
So let me ask you a little
bit about Black History Month
and what it means to you.
We're here to
celebrate that tonight.
So just a little bit, maybe
more, about your heritage
and how you've celebrated
over the years.
I heard you wrote a tribute
to Martin Luther King
when you were 13--
MARGOT B: I did.
RYAN LOREN: --that
still is relevant.
So I think it's really cool
that you're here tonight.
MARGOT B: It was
really funny-- just
to touch on that
story a little bit.
My mother and I were
driving to Philadelphia
for a beauty pageant,
because I really
wanted to be a
part of everything
that they were a part of,
because they were doing
a lot of fund raising and
a lot of volunteer work.
And I thought, that's awesome.
I get to do that all the time?
That sounds like a great idea.
I want to win this thing.
So I went to Philly with my mom.
And when we were in the
car, I just got bored.
And I used to write poems and
songs every once in a while.
But she suggested that
we just write a song.
And she asked me,
what's really important?
And it happened to be
Black History Month.
And I was like, why
don't we write it
about Dr. Martin
Luther King, Jr.?
And she was like, that
sounds like a great idea.
So we sat down-- well,
obviously, she was driving.
But I sat down and just tried
to brainstorm a little bit.
And she helped me think
and figure out my thoughts
and process it and
put it into song form.
And now it's played in
every state in the US
on his birthday, which
is really exciting.
And we did a whole video.
And I incorporated
my high school.
And we got out
for the day, which
was really cool as a kid to
play hooky for a day in school
and shoot my music video.
And then that played
along with the song.
And that gave me a
little bit of acclaim.
But it was all for
the right reasons.
And it was just because
it meant a lot to me.
And coming from such an eclectic
background with my ethnicity
and my family and
religion and everything,
it was just really important
to me to put out that message
and know that it's
still really relevant.
Though it doesn't seem like
things are so restricted now,
we've come very far.
But I think that we still
have many, many moons
to go before the face
of color is extinct.
But it was really
exciting for me
to add to a little piece of
the puzzle as best as I could.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah.
No, I think that's incredible.
It's really commendable.
I know when I was
playing hooky, I
was shooting monsters
on video games.
MARGOT B: I might have done
that on the side, maybe.
RYAN LOREN: So I think it's
really good to have you
because your background
is so different.
And you appreciate
Black History Month.
And also, you give back.
And I wanted to
talk a little bit
about you've volunteered a lot.
And you did a lot for
Katrina in Pittsburgh.
And I just wanted to
see what you've done
and what you're doing now.
MARGOT B: Yeah.
Volunteering has just
always been something
that my heart is drawn to.
We did a Katrina
benefit concert in one
of the biggest arenas in
Pittsburgh, which granted me
a key to the city from
the mayor of Pittsburgh,
which was really cool.
And I was 15.
So that was really nice.
The Red Cross collabed with us.
And my mom and dad and brother
helped me put it together.
And it was really exciting.
We had huge names put it
all together in Pittsburgh.
And we had thousands
of people there.
It was huge.
And we raised a lot of
money for the benefit.
Since I was in "Rent,"
I've had the opportunity
to collab with
Friends In Deed, which
was what "Rent" was
based off of and written,
because of the support
groups dealing with AIDS.
And I dealt a lot with their
main headquarters out of SoHo.
And it was actually
around the same time
that my grandmother passed.
So it was really near
and dear to my heart.
And now, they've
opened up their doors
to not only AIDS survivors or
people that have lost friends
and/or family with
the AIDS virus
but to also cancer survivors
and people that were lost.
So I had the
opportunity to do that.
And I do the AIDS
walk every year.
And I just started
with City Harvest,
which is a great
organization out of Brooklyn.
It's a bit of a trek.
But it's really worth it.
We recently were there.
Because of the theater and
Broadway community as well,
I was invited,
which was amazing.
I've had a lot of
great experiences.
We packed patches of potatoes
and oranges and pears.
And then they go out
to families in need.
And we packed over a ton.
So each sack full of pear or
whatever it is feeds a family.
So that was really
nice to know that we
fed over a couple hundred
families within a couple hours.
And it was fun and exciting.
And I just had the
opportunity to be invited
to a Women Who Cares event
hosted by Loreen Arbus.
And it is based off of
the UCP Foundation, which
is the United Cerebral
Palsy Foundation.
So I'm excited to get
on board with them.
But all of these organizations
are really important to me.
So I'm just trying
to find new ones.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah.
No, you're staying
connected and getting
involved with the community.
I think that's great.
MARGOT B: Yeah.
You've got to get involved
or else nothing changes.
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
So let's switch
gears a little bit.
Talk about music.
What's next for you?
And then we'll get going.
MARGOT B: Well, I'm pumped to
get back on the music train.
I've been writing
a lot and collabing
with a lot of different
producers and writers
and musicians and
just trying to open
my mind to as many
possibilities as I possibly can.
I've come across a
lot of talented people
within my short
term of a career.
And I just keep opening
more and more doors.
And I don't know
how it's happening.
But I'm really blessed.
And so I'm back in
the studio writing
and, hopefully, busting
out some new stuff.
And you can definitely
check me around the city,
because I'm booking shows
everywhere around the city
right now.
And I just can't
wait to get back
on stage just with my
group and do my thing.
And I hope people like it.
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
Well, I'm sure they will.
Margot-- if anyone could
do anything, it's Margot.
She puts her mind to
something, and it happens.
So thanks for being here.
MARGOT B: Thank you.
That's very nice.
RYAN LOREN: We're really looking
forward to having you here.
And good luck with everything.
MARGOT B: Thank you.
RYAN LOREN: All right.